hi this is Jim Parsons you may know me
as a guy who plays a genius on TV but
trust me when I tell you that's acting
his new show is called Jim Parsons is
too stupid for politics and he's kind of
nervous oh I'm scared to death are you
kidding me it's live but uh but it is
what it is look it's the other reason
that word stupid is built into the title
Sheldon may be a brainy app on the Big
Bang Theory but Jim tells us he's had to
do some serious studies my biggest
desire is to try and talk about things
that are going on in government in the
country that from a neutral point of
view from a fact-based point of view the
weekly talk show airs on Sirius XM's
radio and E Channel Andy being Andy
Cohen so far Andy's been a hands-off and
very kind boss and rest assured
Jim's radio gig does not mean he's
leaving his hit sitcom behind I have no
intention to leave the Big Bang Theory
why would I leave leave all this but can
we ever have too much Sheldon too much
Sheldon no Jim is an executive producer
of a big bang spin-off about a teenage
Sheldon and they will cast someone new
to play the lovable nerd I would advise
that actor to watch me as a little as
possible and take that thing by the
horns and make it your own
you